this kid Austin Butler who played Elvis
if I may make an observation uh he made
his speech he won for Elvis but this kid
appears to have turned into Elvis full
time now and the movie's over he listens
to the movies over you got to hear this
I'm going to play here's here's Austin
Butler last night and then I'll play his
voice a year ago before he was Elvis
okay okay
um I I just am so grateful right now I'm
in this room full of my heroes Brad I
love you all right now in 2016 he was
interviewed on MTV here he is tell me if
his if he hasn't gone full method and
become Elvis yeah it was it was a little
overwhelming I didn't realize just how
congested it gets here yeah and uh and I
also was just so impressed with it was
the Jurassic Park stuff I mean I mean
there's no whatever this voice is that
accent that voice
I owe this to uh
Visionary filmmaker who a man named
Colonel Tom pucker who said to me and
Mama you can be a star and I just want
to say this it's a One for the Money Two
For the Show and you know fellow
nominees I know you're in the Heartbreak
Hotel but I want to say are you alone
soon tonight
I want to thank
I want to thank peanut butter and banana
sandwiches
they don't ladies and gentlemen I had a
real blue blue Christmas I mean my
Christmas blue big time
but now I feel better because I'm here
at the Golden Globe
I mean what this kid changed his whole
voice
he became Elvis my name is Austin Butler
forevermore I will be speaking in the
Elvish voice
and I'll tell you why
I hear there's going to be a sequel
baslerman is pitching me on Elvis goes
to space
[Music]
and I want all those over impersonators
to send me 10 percent of their income
all my name is Austin Butler but I sound
like Elvish now full time
and a matter of fact I want you to look
forward in 2024 to Elvis kilt's Bigfoot
and then Hitler that's right coming soon
Elvis versus Godzilla Japanese film
Elvis vampire Hunter
four
[ __ ] you Jacob elardi thank you
you're not
that the kid totally changed his voice
Robin wow totally changed his voice